Please welcome the one and only, Judd Apatow.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
Hi, Drew.
(audience applauds)
Good to see you.
(audience cheers)
(Judd laughs)
Okay, we go back a really long way.
Yes.
Like long, long way.
The first time I ever directed,
I directed Drew the first time.
Maybe the first scene I ever directed.
At "The Larry Sanders Show."
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
That was a very scary day for me
because I never even was sure I wanted to be a director.
And one day, Garry just walked into my office
and went, "You're doing the next one."
And-
Why do you think
he said that?
What did he see in you?
I just think he thought I'd be good at it.
And then he sent me into war with you and Jeffrey Tambor
and Rip Torn.
Oh, my God, who is kind of notoriously difficult.
He was complicated.
The first time I shot a scene with him, he's,
we were shooting the scene
and I was just scared to say anything.
I just thought I'll get six takes from Rip and say nothing.
I'll have enough.
I'm not gonna tell him to do anything.
And they do the first take.
And then he looks at the cinematographer
and he goes like, "What are you doing?
You're shooting my ear."
(audience laughs)
And the camera was like right in front of him.
Like, it didn't even make sense.
(Drew and audience laughing)
And then the guy's like, "I'm right here, Rip."
And he's like, "I know the angles. I shoot skeet."
(audience laughs)
That was my first day of work.
All right, so you get a bite of the apple?
Yes.
And is it like, that's it, you're in?
Well, I did think, oh, I guess I can do this.
So I remember when you brought baby Maude
when you were doing rewrites on "The Wedding Singer."
Now, you were roommates with Adam Sandler.
Yes, yes I was. (laughs)
And-
Well, we were like
fresh out of college, we lived together.
Oh, there you go.
Ah.
I mean, come on. Look at you!
(Judd laughs)
No!
Well, I was getting,
(audience laughs)
I was getting my headshots for stand-up comedy,
and then Adam just jumped into the shot.
(audience laughs)
Well, tell me something only a roommate
would know about Sandler.
Well, back then, we didn't really have anything to do
because we would just do stand-up at night.
And so all day, every day, we had to kill the day.
And Adam had a lot of energy to be funny.
If you could imagine, like he didn't have an outlet other
than his like 15 minutes at night.
And so he would be really funny with us all day.
And so I remember once we went to Red Lobster, and-
Those commercials are such porn.
Right?
I mean,
if that doesn't get you hot,
(audience laughs)
that wet lemon squeezing.
Exactly.
Well-lit.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
Like
(audience applauds)
God, that creamy noodle being whirled.
Exactly.
(Drew laughs)
And back then,
you don't even think
that anything's unhealthy, right?
I used to have like two fettuccine Alfredos.
I would ask for a double.
That's how I ate at that age every night.
And like one in the morning in improv,
I would eat a double fettuccine Alfredo.
You are my kind of guy.
(Judd laughs)
So we'd go to Red Lobster,
and it's just me and Adam alone, eating there.
And then Adam would try to humiliate me in spaces, you know?
So if you were like in an elevator with Adam
and other people, he would always like fart, and go, "Judd!"
(audience laughs)
But all the time.
Every time there was an elevator, you're like,
"I don't wanna go in there with you."
(audience laughs)
And so we're eating dinner and he like farts.
(laughs) So he just rips?
And it's a terrible one.
And then he's like,
(Drew laughs)
"Judd, we're at a fancy restaurant."
(audience laughs)
And then I'm just like, (sighs)
I was just like so mad, I'm eating,
and then like 10 seconds later, a little kid,
like a five-year-old, just goes,
"Mommy, how come I can't smell it?"
(Drew and audience laughing)
And then Adam cracks up like the biggest laugh ever,
runs out of the restaurant,
and just leaves me alone at the table.
(Drew and audience laughing)
(upbeat pop music)